isn't it your son's birthday soon yeah I
had I had his birthday on Easter so I
had the eggs Jesus and his birthday
rolled into one your son because we were
just out here talking about kids with
Kristina she said her her her daughter
is six how old is your son my son
Jeffrey will be 12 years old
oh no that's a whole different ballgame
I guess I'm not gonna lie you know it
having a boy I'm a boys type of mother
but he's going into this different
season counted like I was tucking him in
bed he said mommy can I tell you
something and I said yeah Jeffrey when
he said my penis keeps freezing up like
you mean like it can't make a decision I
don't know I've never had that Conan
yeah and I said I said Jeffrey who does
it frees up around and he said not you
mommy and I was like well thanks for let
you spend like my ex-husband and he says
where it freezes up around Beyonce oh if
he sees Beyonce on TV Beyonce on TV he's
his penis freezes up she better be glad
she pregnant I'd whoop my ass lead my
son down the dark road yeah you can't be
having that
you